a casi tres semanas de las elecciones de
medio término la situación económica de
Estados Unidos es uno de los temas clave
de la agenda política y es que la
amenaza de una posible recesión está
cada vez más vigente Y la inflación
continúa siendo alta con el aumento de
los precios de los alimentos un 13,5% en
los últimos 12 meses los sondeos de
opinión muestran que la economía es la
prioridad número uno de los votantes
algunas de las novedades de estas
elecciones de medio mandato son los
temas que importan a los votantes en
esta ocasión es la inflación la
inflación ha sido del 9% año tras año y
eso está realmente en la mente de la
gente
según una encuesta decidies news el 68%
de los estadounidenses estima que el
gobierno de Joe biden podría hacer más
para combatir la inflación un argumento
de peso para los adversarios del
presidente que le acusan de minimizar
dificultades económicas de los
estadounidenses
le preocupa la fortaleza del dólar en
estos momentos
no me preocupa la fortaleza del dólar me
preocupa el resto del mundo tiene
sentido puede explicarlo
Sí nuestra economía es muy fuerte y la
inflación está en todo el mundo está
peor en todas las otras partes que en
Estados Unidos así que el problema Es la
falta de crecimiento económico y de
políticas sólidas en otros países no
tanto en el nuestro las elecciones del 8
de noviembre en las que los votantes
eligen a los congresistas y gobernadores
se celebran dos años después de las
presidenciales y son una suerte de
referéndum sobre la política del
mandatario de turno a finales de agosto
los demócratas vieron sus esperanzas
aumentar respecto a la posibilidad de
conservar una mayoría en el senado e
incluso en la cámara de representantes
pero las últimas encuestas indican que
los votantes independientes cruciales en
un contexto de fuerte polarización
inclinar la balanza a favor de los
republicanos